j'accueille andré lamy
[Musique]
il est belge qui n'a que 24 ans qui
s'appelle eric lamy andré lamy
olympia
la saison commence bien
tanel chanter la mer
ce soir c'est pour lui le sommet de la
gloire
m
le soir
à
rosie a rendez vous avec la lune
chacune jeu 13 heures la lunella la une
est là
une alarme et vouziers
oui
il faut les ménager
c'est ainsi que mozilla rendez vous
ça
tout le monde en a parlé à retrouver
andré lamy à bruxelles
chaque matin sur bel rtl la radio la
plus écoutée en belgique francophone il
égratigne la famille royale ainsi que
tous les barons politiques nationaux
autant voter pour moi ton rouge je me
suis arrangée avec bart de wever
jusqu'à ce que le ps et 80 %
d'intentions de vote en wallonie et à
bruxelles et puis on fera enfin un
gouvernement et puis on va aux élections
une émission très écouté dans la veine
de ce que nicolas canteloup et laurent
gerra fonds en france matin j'étais très
inspiré et d'ailleurs j'ai un scoop
qu'est-ce que j'ai un scoop quoi j'ai eu
un message de du coprésident d'écolo
pouf et jean michel javaux qui a dit à
8h38 grandiose votez pour moi
aujourd'hui inspiré de berriane
rentrer en belgique andré lamy a su
retrouver un second souffle avec la
satire politique la renaissance d'andré
en belgique francophone s'est faite au
travers de la radio et de voter pour moi
en belgique il a trouvé le filon en fait
ça ne m'étonnerait pas que dans les mois
qui viennent ou l'année qui vient ils
jouent une pièce à paris c'est toujours
un risque quand on prend un imitateur
qui est
- dans les feux de l'actualité la
critique souvent nous tombe dessus sur
10 ans mais qu'est ce qu'ils ont encore
été chercher andré lamy c'est quand même
incroyable ya quand même d'autres et ben
oui il y en a d'autres mais andres est
meilleur
la satire politique c'est un genre très
pratiqué en france mais plus rares en
belgique la caricature politique en
belgique ces récentes des imitateurs qui
font les hommes politiques y en a qu'un
seul je suis le seul à avoir investi
l'émission terminée andré entame son
marathon de la journée bonjour radio
télé internet andré lamy joue de tous
les médias alors cette semaine c'est pas
possible tu as motion s'envolait avant
de continuer sa journée de travail andré
nous fait découvrir son appartement où
il vit seul alors voilà on a des mots
différents pour les choses par exemple
si vous avez ça on appelle cette chemise
ap c'est une cheminée ma ps1 trouvèrent
par exemple êtes plus à la moquette
c'est du tapis plein ici
alors quand on peut constater et s'est
amusé le verdict et l'on découvre sa
passion pour le plus célèbre duo comique
[Musique]
dès lors les relie tous les bouquins qui
ont été faits sur eux tout ce qui
concerne les photos de réservistes
chauriens d'envoi 2002 5 original ça
c'est une chose intéressante ici parce
que c'est surtout des objets datant des
années et des années 30
il y en a encore
alors et la sécurité
voilà sa cinématique personnel
pellicule donc voilà l'antre de la bête
très populaire en belgique andré lamy ne
regrette t-il pas le vedettariat
français moi j'ai une vie magnifique
je suis parti de pas grand chose pour
arriver pas très loin mais je ne sais
pas j'ai une vie qui
je suis où je suis bien où y'a pas de
prise de tête il ya pas deux
suis je suis assez heureux de ma vie
même si je vis seule je suis assez vrai
dans ma vie quoi direction maintenant le
comedy central de charleroi une petite
salle où ils rôdent son futur spectacle
[Musique]
est gardé en mai dernier il ya eu il ya
eu une manifestation à bruxelles pour
vous pour l'unité de la belgique il y
avait mille personnes à cette
manifestation le même jour et à la gay
pride
quarante mille personnes quand je vous
dis que ce pays part en couilles je suis
pas loin de la vérité à nos hôtes de jo
hennon de guédelon diop et voilà
un spectacle qu andré lamy jouera dans
toute la belgique et peut-être aussi en
france si le public le réclame à nouveau
je peux pas dire je suis demandeur
ici je fais tout je fais du space
cheveux du spectacle je fais de la télé
je fais de l'internet fait de la radio
je suis pas su que je pourrais faire la
même chose à paris et puis ici à la
différence de mes collègues français
je suis seul à faire ce que je fais au
royaume des imitateurs andré lamy est le
roi des belges
[Musique]
et maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
andré lamy
bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue dans tous n'en
a parlé merci alors andré vous êtes né
le 31 octobre 1962 à ixelles en belgique
et vous avez passé votre enfance à
schaerbeek votre vrai nom c'est leveugle
vais t'appeler lamy à cause de serge la
main c'est ça tout à fait un faux mal
fait ou un non c'est sûr a dit lamy oui
alors dit votre plus jeune âge est
passionné par l'imitation votre première
invitation vous avez 10 11 ans était
ringo oui c'est vrai et le ring au
débiteur sung au chellah pour le rigodon
sheila comme j'ai pas été aussi loin
et là vous enregistrer une musique à 7
et vous la portez à votre maman et jean
salis regarde ma montre qui cette
adresse à tout à fait vous aviez fait la
chanson caroulle une trop belle pour
rester seul
c'est très fiers donc de savoir éviter
quelqu'un vous aviez envie d'être
quelqu'un a oublié sortir du lot convenu
du multi un jeu je voulais faire rire
ouais ça c'était mon truc a fait rire
vers 7 8 ans ira votre première
invitation vous racontiez à tout le
monde vous étiez le fils de redire oui
j'étais fanas de roger bourgade
amicalement vôtre à l'époque échouer ces
distinctions etc
peut-être un papa de substitution euros
voilà alors votre premier spectacle en
public c'est à l'âge de 16 ans à l'école
vous imitez devos de funès claude
françois serge la main ça ma mère était
très elle adorerait tout ce qui était
variété on passait notre devis devant la
télé à regarder les émissions de
variétés les carpentier et c est moi
j'ai été baigné là-dedans quoi donc et
comme ma mère était un peu une artiste
frustré bien voulu faire un et qui était
question de grandes surfaces la pauvre
ben là peu ça beaucoup d'états sur moi
et donc j'ai fait ça oui mais vous allez
travailler dans les grandes surfaces
bord de chariots sur les parkings oui et
caissiers 2 et j'étais la poissonnerie
carrière
alors à 18 ans vous lancer dans le monde
du spectacle au festival de rochefort
belgique qui est un tremplin et là vous
finissez parmi les finalistes oui mais
je suis dernier défi de la liste mais
quand même je sais très vite arrêté et
là je me suis demandé si j'allais
continuer ou pas donc voilà je vous
décidez d'en faire un métier à ce moment
là on faisons comme eux je suis quand
même fait du droit à l'université libre
de bruxelles mais très vite c'est ça m'a
pas plu voilà alors première scène à 21
ans black bottom à bruxelles et puis de
la radio vous fait ça je trouve génial
le titre de votre émission de la folie
des grandeurs ah oui c'est sûr s y est
ce que tu me radio un blocage et j'ai
connu le début des radios libres où
c'était une liberté totale et j'ai
appris mon métier là en fait main et
vous êtes photographié sur scène vont en
train d'imiter glandus le personnage
créé par thierry le luron qui venait de
mourir la photo paraît dans paris match
belgique on comprend pas très bien
pourquoi mais elle se retrouve sur le
bureau de hubert wii qui étaient les
producteurs de thierry le luron et de
bien d'autres et les hubert vous demande
une cassette vous leur envoyez une
cassen et il vous demande de travailler
avec oui en même temps j'étais très
méfiant je suis allé voir un avocat tout
de suite ils vont me rouler
et puis quand je suis arrivé là bas je
suis tombé sur des gens extrêmement
honnête et très droit et aimons que si
un contrat de cinq ans et je me suis dit
allez j'y fais quoi ouais donc à 24 ans
vous prêtez votre belgique natale pour
vous installer apparaît tout à fait en
fête premier à paris étaient très bien
organisés c'était au tintamarre voyez
tout le monde arrivait drucker il est
fou qu il y avait deux chavannes il y
avait le cas bâches ont bien monté le
coup quand gilles paquet y était pour
beaucoup alors très vite c'est le succès
à vous donner la star française de
limitation le successeur de le luron
vous êtes partout d'abord sur l'europe
avec film gilda et cri du geai de la
souris pendant trois ans ouais fait
l'ami public numéro un
c'était autre chose que la radio libre
un autre professionnel moi j'ai traversé
c'est un peu comme sa brosse tous
arrivés boum boum voilà et puis france
inter avec l'énergie aussi oui il ya
deux ans de folie un défaut fait quatre
spectacles par jour oui la première
année je veux dire d'exploitation tente
réclamer pour être passé à 400
spectacles dans l'année un rythme de fou
et vous allez dîner avec mitterrand une
fois pourquoi parce qu'il devait venir
otamment à voir le spectacle et puis il
ya eu un gouvernement qui a dû tomber
votre comme ça on a vu les motards qui
étaient venus pour voir les tissus etc
et puis c'est par jacques attali qu'on a
eu que j'ai eu un repas à l'elysée avec
lui et jack lang à l'époque il vous a
dit quoi mitterrand un lien non mais
j'ai dit que c'était assez apprécié 24
balles elles vont trouver de vendée qui
m'a pratiquement pas adressé la parole
d'ailleurs et
vous attendez ses imitations non plus
mais ce qui m'intéressait beaucoup
jacques attali à l'époque c'est que je
faisais là mitterrand muet c'est qu'il
faut continuer à lui ça ne l'arrangé
évident alors on vous voit l'olympia au
casino de paris au gymnase alors avec
vos grands classiques de funès deauville
la main sardou mitterrand c'est qu'ils
que vous preniez le plus de plaisir à
imiter à l'époque la b2 de funès et
devos devos parce que c'était un poète
mais c'est tout c'est un génie oui et
puis en plus comme il m'avait très
gentil bord dit qu'il était mon parrain
dans le métier c'est jacques chancel qui
me l'avait fait rencontrer là ça a été
un truc de fou alors vous avez une
réussite fulgurante qui est dû sans
doute à la disparition de le luron être
coluche rue pratiquement simultanément
quoi oui tout à fait alors oui les
rendre il ya un vide en fait mais je
faisais plus de comédiens que le luron
c'est pas pareil sébastien était nouveau
spectacle en me disant tu t'y as plus de
moi que de le luron enfin c'était un peu
un mix des deux aurait gagné voilà
quelle a été la réaction de son
entourage quand vous avez eu cet énorme
succès mon père a toujours pris ça assez
mal à mon père voulait que je sois
policiers
il avait beaucoup d'ambition pour quoi
et moi je ne rêvais que de faire ça donc
je suis parti assez tôt de chez moi pour
faire ce métier là je dis pas que j'ai
moi j'ai mangé de la vache enragée moi
je te dire que j'ai gagné
un peu d'argent au début
et après à paris qui s'est ouvert à moi
d'une façon assez un peu accidentelle
quoi c'est pas un truc que j'ai que j'ai
voulu mais une fois que c'est arrivé
effectivement je le suis moins frais
quoi ça c'est clair et et votre maman a
trouvé dans votre carrière finalement
quelque chose qui a compensé ses
frustrations tout à fait et en même
temps ils avaient tous les deux très
peur que ça s'arrête voilà et vos amis
j'ai jamais eu beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'amis et h quelqu'un très
solitaire meilleur en ce moment vous
habitez seul oui enfin l'ol et redire
mon chat c'est votre chalet
4d gagne de l'argent à l'époque
beaucoup plus qu'on ne croit et moi
qu'on pense
oui non j'ai gagné ma vie oui mais
j'avais trois producteurs j'avais gilles
paquet hervé philippe hubert donc ça
faisait beaucoup de gens à nourrir vous
n'avez pas mis de l'argent de côté pour
plus rien faire non non non ce genre
assure des missions de monde se pose pas
du tout alors est question amour ça vous
a aidé pas du tout oui ça m'a aidé oui
parce que c'est vrai que ça tomber des
arbres un moment alors que j'avais une
vie amoureuse ces normes avant ça et
puis surtout il y en a une qui m'a mis
krapane celui qui m'a fait un enfant
pour que je me suis trouvé dans le bain
assez vite oui
voilà un petit garçon qui à 21 ans
aujourd'hui
quel était le meilleur moment de cette
époque
le fait de me prouver à moi même que je
pouvais y arriver voilà ça c'était
c'était très bonne thérapie en fait moi
qui ai cavité un gamin c'était eux qui
restent au fond de la classe qui
bougeait pas du jour au lendemain ça m'a
donné plus d'assurance larry avocat
suisse où il s'était tout est relatif
mais j'ai oui j'étais c'était très
agréable avec toujours comme chez
pessimiste de nature je me disais
toujours pourvu que ça dure un peu comme
laetitia bonaparte et vise à continuer
pourquoi vous y croyez pas assez
peut-être non ça a été très très vite
beaucoup trop vite d'ailleurs je me
rendais compte même au moment où j'étais
mais en même temps on se dit ça va trop
vite mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait freiner
c'est difficile d'autant plus qu'on a
toujours cherché à voir ça alors une
fois que ça arrive ça arrive on essaie
de le gérer ou du mieux qu'on peut et
c'est vrai que je pense que l'erreur
vient de moi et aussi de l'erreur des
producteurs ne suis pas tout seul dans
le truc mais on a fait tous une erreur
voilà c'est tout quel a été le pire
moment à l'époque bella chute
justement là ça commence à 1 - sourire
oui
vous êtes le premier quand même à qui on
propose d'être l'imitateur des guignols
8 vous travaillez que gildas donc
c'était assez naturelle mais vous
refusez et vous refusez par là-même
finalement la puissance du média télé
nothing et la branchitude de canal+
c'est à dire moi j'avais pas refuser moi
j'aurais bien voulu le faire et ce sont
les producteurs qui voyait à l'époque ne
t'inquiète pas ça marchera jamais et
donc il était visionnaire et et puis
j'ai raté le truc oui j'ai jamais le
caricaturiste j'aime les marionnettes
j'aime tout ce qui est déjà d'or ça et
donner ma voix des trucs comme ça qu'on
sait ce qu'il a fait aujourd'hui à la à
la radio en belgique
cbg jamais j'ai toujours aimé ça j'ai
pas eu l'opportunité de le faire il y
avait aussi bon philippe avait dit à
l'époque tu sais andré est ce que tu
sais fait ppda il
faudrait que j'essaye et puis après il
m'a dit bon écoute et ils ont choisi
yves lecoq et puis très bien je veux
dire c'est comme ça c'est comme ça c'est
la vie
et pareil avec le bébête show alors le
bébête show c'est encore autre chose
c'est-à-dire que les marionnettes
appartenait à tf1 le concept appartenait
à collaro et on a eu dominique cantien
qui est de nous voir au tintamarre avec
un chèque en blanc dix ans signé a été
le chiffre que vous voulez et on
aimerait vous fassiez les voies et là ça
c'est moi qui ai pas voulu parce que je
voulais pas rentrer dans les pompes de
vos casques quoi se tenait ouais ouais
nan parce que j'estimais que c'était son
truc à lui j'aurais fait du sourou casse
ce qui n'avait pas d'intérêt quoi alors
le problème c'est que quand vous faites
de la télévision c'est sur l'a5 avec
marie ange nardi on la produit par
michel lafon qui est sans doute un bon
éditeur mais qui n'a jamais rien fait
d'autre en télévision que cette émission
qui s'appelait grain de folie dont il y
avait des problèmes dans la peau à
l'époque
formaté il écoute il ya une opportunité
c'est de faire ça
moi j'ai tout de suite mis les choses au
point je suis pas animateur je n'ai
jamais été animateur je serai jamais ali
matters hermétique je ne connais pas je
ne sais pas faire et on m'a dit oui mais
tu as vu l'argent qui a gagné et c'est
j'écoute est plutôt les sirènes de
l'argent plutôt que le côté qualité on
m'avait dit aussi tu seras le le
trublion de l'émission d co animateur et
j'étais co animateur et et là moi je
t'aimais je me voyais à la télé je suis
3e ça a été douloureux c'est dur à wil
canton quand on n'est pas fait pour ça
c'est très dur un très habile à 5 e quoi
qu'ils racontaient les patrons à
l'époque il n'y avait pas vraiment de
raison un panneau il y avait personne
n'envoyait l'émission alors on nous
disait oui mais sur les gens qui
regardent on est leader oui
il ya quand même eu entre temps un truc
assez grave pour vous en tous les cas
c'est le spectacle sur mitterrand oui
oui parce que mitterrand cancer de la
prostate ce n'était pas le moment de se
moquer de lui oui c'était un spectacle
s'appelait liberté égalité terminée où
on avait fait faire un crâne pour moi de
mitterrand j'étais mitterrand du début à
la fin du spectacle et ça passe tout en
revue les affaires les machins les trucs
et puis à part trois semaines je crois
de la première au sein de honda annonce
dans la presse et par tous il était en
concert de la prostate et là toutes les
portes sont fermées à vitesse v v prime
voilà on l'a présenté mais ça a été ça
m'a coûté beaucoup d'argent oui j'étais
co producteurs de two way donc ça m'a
coûté beaucoup d'argent quand vous
rentrez en belgique ouais la queue entre
les jambes dites vous oui
oui oui attendez on va pas non plus
quand on apprend quand on prend une
baffe pareil on vient l'essai de revenir
modestement
alors aujourd'hui vous êtes nostalgique
de cette époque cette grande époque
dillon parisienne nostalgique c'est pas
le mot g j'ai aimé la voir je lui eus on
peut pas me l'enlever déjà c'était une
chose et puis et puis voilà et puis je
veux dire que grâce à ça aujourd'hui je
continue à faire carrière dans ce métier
je n'aurais pas eu cette période jeudi
heure française en belgique je n'aurais
pas pu faire tout ce que je fais
aujourd'hui si c'était à refaire
qu'est-ce que vous ne referiez pas
pareil je ne passerai pas du tintamarre
à la michodière aux quatre mois déjà
le truc c'est que c'est allé très vite
parce que il y avait des gens moi je moi
j'étais pas aussi gourmand que même un
très court brian c'est ça voilà c'est
l'argent en fait comme toujours
le nerf de la guerre mon bon monsieur
qu'est-ce que vous mettriez sur vos
tombes si on vous demandait une épitaphe
j'ai bien ri
j'adore rires j'adore faire rire et
j'adore j'adore m'amuser j'ai toujours
fait ce métier en m'amusant mais
aujourd'hui vous avez à vous amuser sur
un gel non à un pays aussi on peut
s'amuser mais service vraiment pour ça
c'est formidable c'est un très beau
petit royaume c'est pas pour très
longtemps peut-être plus pour très
longtemps non parce qu'on a un roi de
flandre maintenant il a envie d'avoir la
place de l'autre j'ai très heureux de
rallumer la lumière sur vous merci en
mars merci à vous
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
hinault l'attitude abonnez vous y mettez
un peu de bleu